请不吝点赞 订阅 转发 打赏支持明镜与点点栏目
字幕志愿者 李宗盛
好,大家晚安
這個
有點小聲喔
啊,這樣子靠近一點
靠近一點應該就大聲了齁
好啦,這個我們要來今天的直播齁
你的股票呢,是大戶的聚寶盆呢這個還是垃圾桶好 那我們今天就來看一下看你的股票是哪一類那最近呢
有一檔股票喔
非常威喔
這檔股票目前是
全台灣投資人的最愛
這叫00981A
00981A
00981A齁
最近的籌碼很誇張
給各位看一個東西啊
最近受到這個
國泰敦蘭
國泰敦蘭各位也知道是誰啦
就是散戶的分點齁
那這個國泰敦蘭最近
這個非常的愛
這個981
為什麼啊因為
買它沒輸過啊
沒有輸過
買981齁隨便買啦
隨便買怎麼買怎麼賺
怎麼買怎麼賺
導致這個國泰敦蘭
國安都難喔 國安都難就一直加碼
一直加碼喔
那昨天還
有人說沒聲音喔
聲音應該有喔
昨天還這個超大的溢價
昨天溢價啦
溢價大概1 2%
那1 2%呢就會有人去
申購
去申購來做
來做套利
這個昨天有這邊
前兩天呢 這邊有人做這個
欸 龍券
喔 做龍券
喔 龍券 這應該是
來套的啦
來套的
喔 反正有人來套了 有人來吃他豆腐啦
981A已經大到這個投資人在
應該說大戶在吃豆腐了
因為你只要
你只要
呃 規模很大 然後
溢價的話
齁 那就會有人來吃豆腐
齁 那這981A呢他的
這個
操盤人很厲害啦齁
齁 這個
操盤人很厲害
齁 所以導致呢981A的
齁 我們來看一下齁
981A的
績效呢 也很好
那981A呢 買了哪些股票
台光店建設 智邦 齊鴻
買這些
各位看一下
他選股選這些
都選一些好股票
選一些好股票那有些股票是比較高價的像南電啊南南電 旺系
台光電 台達電 台積電
這都算比較智邦啊 齊永啊
金像電啊
都是比較高價的股票
那比較高價的股票本來它的
它的籌碼呢也會比較安定
低價的比較容易不安定
那比較高價比較安定
那目前為止齁其實981N
在一個良性循環
目前還在一個良性循環啦
良性循環就是
這個
良性循環是這樣子啦
就是
投資人有信心
那投資人呢就繼續買
繼續買
那繼續買981A要幹嘛呢
981A就要繼續的
這個再買股
再買股票
因為你們買981A啊
981A就要繼續的
買股票
那981A買股票呢 有的就買自己的成分股
那買自己的成分股呢 就導致怎麼樣
就導致自己成分股又漲
又漲齁
所以呢 他這個就是一個良性循環
良性循環
那這個
等到有一天
出現惡性循環的時候 那時候就會變成多殺多
那有沒有這麼一天呢
我跟各位講 這一天一定會出現
一定會出現 只是不曉得什麼時候出現
現在我也不知道什麼時候出現
一定會有這麼一天啦
就是要多殺多的時候
那不是最近
那各位也不用期待它馬上發生
然後你也不用很緊張很恐懼
反正你就等著看
等著看9811哪一天規模開始變小
9811每天賣超的金額變大
他每天純賣超股票的話
那時候你要跑再跑就可以了
現在也不用跑 現在是一個
這個
多拉多的時候
不是多殺多 多拉多
現在就是
投資人相信這個981A
然後呢 投資人就繼續買
給我們看到 幾百戶數一直增加
投資人繼續買
國太多人一直買
那這個月
這個禮拜沒意外 又要再創高
因為他最近創高的幅度呢
我是覺得幅度有點誇張
喔 幅度有點誇張
喔 原本43萬戶 變成49萬戶
呵呵 太誇張了
好 那以前呢 我們
呃 跟各位講不要碰的940呢一路的往下掉一路往下掉各位看到沒有這從我們一開始跟各位講這不能碰我們之前有跟各位講
940不能碰
但是呢 我們沒有講981A不能碰
因為981A呢
他一開始規模比較小
慢慢變大
那981A你現在要買 可以
那你要記得一件事
等到981A開始
賣股票的時候
現在每天你可以看
981A他每天都在買股票
他每天都要買股票
因為他的規模還在膨脹
規模還在膨脹 你就不用怕
他的規模一直膨脹
就是投資人一直買
他就一直買自己的成分股
或者是買一些新的股票
他一直買呢
當然這個資金一直進來
那這個股價的人越來越高
股價越來越高
那現在大家都不管本益比
本益比什麼東西啊
都不用碰 不用理他
不用管本益比
這個大家現在進來都不管風險了
不管風險
好 那這個00940蠻好玩的
00940這個自從突破10塊之後
哇 它的規模呢 急劇的下降
為什麼 因為大家受不了
一開始還緩跌
到突破10塊之後變暴跌
然後被暴跌 為什麼 因為終於解套
終於解套
那其實940呢 其實在
它的規模變小之後
變小之後 比較好啦
那同樣的喔 我跟各位講
981A後面呢 會出現一個問題
他後面會出現一個問題啊
他問題是這樣子啦 就是
981A後面的問題是這樣子
等到有一天呢
981A他在減碼股票的時候
981A呢 他在減碼股票的時候
我具體來講啦 他在賣台光店
假設啦 假設他開始賣台光電
他一賣台光電
所以大家看到他在賣台光電就怎麼樣
趕緊砍台光電
他的那個
砍的速度呢 會比他快很多
因為
這9萬億的
他的
規模太大嘛
有時候砍股票可能一兩天砍不完
但是他只要一減碼
大家拚命的砍
像這樣他只要一買股票
大家拚命的搶進去
大家拚命搶進去
搶進去他買的
他買的股票
大家會批評買
搶進去他買的股票
所以呢各位呢
這個
你可以
你就可以那個
來研究一下
這981呢
他
他最近在幹嘛
981在幹嘛
好
這個
主動式ETF的變化
各位呢
你可以去看
小雨的投資日記
來來來來
推一下
這個有興趣的看一下
小雨的投資日記
這邊都有
哇
這個4月21號
主動式ETF籌碼快報
台積電呢
增加9%
台光電增加7%
台達電增加6%
建設增加6%有沒有看到
都在增加
剪码出去
實在變緊張
這個本來就很少
一次歸零
但是呢只要
各位看一下
他這個大部分都在增加
大部分都在增加
大部分這個
看起來
大部分的贓入都在增加
為什麼 因為它規模在變大
有沒有 它規模在變大
喔 那規模在變大呢
它就容易
這個 就是增壓持股嘛
所以跟各位講
它光買自家的股票
買一買它的禁止就上去了啦
喔 光買自家的股票
買一買禁止就上去了
這個就是
這個是一個規模越來越大的
厲害的地方
喔 你來買我
你買我 我就買我的成分股
我買我的成分股呢
我的禁止又變大
我變大之後呢 你又更愛我
那你又繼續買我的成分
繼續買我的ETF
你再買我的ETF
我又必須去買我的成分股
然後呢 就導致怎麼樣
就導致一個
非常良性的循環
那各位呢 你可以注意一下
看他每天再加碼哪些股票
哇 這台積電也可以
可以一天買
這一天買幾張啊
這一天買700 800多張也真的太厲害
各位你看一下
每天買的張數啊 真的
真的很誇張欸 有沒有
欸這這
這股價不是很便宜的欸
尹薇喔 一天可以買
這可以買幾張喔
各位我們簡直可以去算他的那個
他一天到底佔了
佔了這些成分股幾%
那各位講他目前是處於一個那個像吹泡泡一樣吹泡泡越吹越大那等到有一天我們就關注一下
各位可以密切關注一下
看一下這個981A
什麼時候突然的在
大量的賣股票
它現在還在買股票
好不好 還在買股票
那各位呢 你現在可以密切關注這個最大型
因為目前
這個主動型ETF
來我查一下
主動型ETF的規模裡面齁
這個規模裡面最大就981A啦
所以各位目前
目前可以看一下
哇看一下
欸對啊981A最大
主動型ETF981A最大
981A最大
規模恐怖啊
這個這個看一下看一下
唉唷
這裡
各位看一下
主動型 欸?這規模是真的假的啊
有這麼少嗎
資產規模
981A 982A 991A 992A 有嗎?
你看這邊
這個主動型規模是越來越大
越來越大
然後呢這個
呃...主動型規模越來越大
然後那個
高股息的ETF規模越來越小
越來越小
因為都跑去主動型了
主動型太厲害了
那現在就是在一個
膨脹的過程啊
反正在一個膨脹過程中
以下這幾檔股票
這幾檔股票
各位呢你就可以怎麼樣
你就可以把它列入自選啦
好不好
列入自選
來來來
我教各位啊
我們可以把它列入自選
好來
我新增群組
981A
00981A 列如自選
來 貼上
有沒有 好來 貼上
來 各位 981A 我們就直接把
唉唷 唉唷 怎麼沒了
等一下 我們要確定
唉唷 等一下
我看一下 981A 可以了
來 我看一下 我把它關掉一下
關掉一下 我們直接來看 981A的股票
這個
看981A的股票當沖神器喔 當沖神器好
981A
喔 有沒有看到
目前東洋是稍微減碼
東洋減碼
這股票看起來不怎麼樣
981A有買東窑
好 然後這裡面呢
這個買比較多的是
這個銀威啊 哇
銀威
銀威就佔19%
微影佔18%
這個建設啊
投信喔 最近買了蠻多的
來看一下藍店
這有捐藍店被電
其實我藍店也不算被電啦
因為我本來就在做一個
這個雙刀
給各位看一下我的今天對賬單
來
這裡我的對賬單
今天的全家嗨
全家嗨一檔
一檔嗨全家
來這邊對賬單喔各位
這裡面呢
我幾乎都做多啦
做多做多 望虹我做多啊
望虹我昨天買的
蠻漂亮的
喔 哇
跟各位講的那個
Fresh沒有這麼爛
好不好 各位 記憶體沒有這麼爛
我現在為記憶體平反一下
記憶體沒有這麼爛啊
其實在下通道是個好蠻甜
喔
記憶體沒有這麼爛
好不好
喔 啊 記憶體現在大家
這個
很害怕
其實記憶體的基本面真的很好
他現在呢 在做一個
籌碼面的
這個修正
做籌碼面的修正啊
所以現在的這個
因為它的籌碼很爛
記憶體就是籌碼爛
什麼都好 就籌碼爛
籌碼線寫爛
那基本面很好
那這時候呢 這個有衝突嘛
所以呢 記憶體呢 你也不要太看多
那也不用去空它
因為這個位置我是覺得
肉也可能也不多
可能有一開始就
可能有時候一反彈 反彈就被咬到
所以呢 通常記憶體
比如說像望遠這種來到一個下通道
不要去追空了
我昨天在這下通道 我就 蠻划算的嘛
去買一下
今天立馬一根漲停啦
好買不多啦買不多那各位這邊做多 做多新興新興我主要做多不是在不是在期貨
我主要做多呢是在現股
在跟各位講
新興呢
我主要做多在現股
所以我現股那邊的新興的獲利
應該是五六百啦
五六百
目前跟南電比起來
這個新興
可能也不只啦 我看一下
我看一下我的星星
喔 那個在
就在這邊喔
等一下 我把我的星星看一下
我看一下我的星星
我的旅約
最近我的旅約 等一下
帳戶
我看一下我對帳看一下
對賬單
因為主要的新興的對賬單呢
我很多都放在
這個獻股上面
所以呢
我要看一下我獻股的對賬單
3037 有啦
這邊很多個 哇 有有有
這裡很多個 等一下把它
弄給各位看 這裡
這邊啦
我貼在這裡齁
對
這3037啊
我從那個
高價往下貼
就獲利多的往下貼啊
你看這邊200
3037這邊
現在有庫存
大概400多
目前呢我
新星也有庫存啊
庫存我看一下
庫存目前的星星呢
看一下
目前的星星還有五十幾萬
所以加一加星星應該賺了快五百萬
星星賺了快五百
然後呢
在加
其實我是這樣子配的
我是星星加景碩配藍店
我是買星星買景碩空藍店
再跟各位講
買星星買景碩空南電
我在做那個
我們叫雙刀戰法
雙刀戰法
那明天景碩會變
欸
但是不要講啦
反正這個
明天我們有明天的雙刀
明天有明天的雙刀
那這幾天呢是
買星星買景碩空藍店
那還是賺錢
藍店算這樣子喔
其實
星星加景碩
在扣掉藍店的虧損
整體組合是賺的
因為我們有做這種組合
所以呢
我們的部位可以放得很大
所以你看藍店我做了三十幾口
那星星跟景碩
星星我有
欸星星跟景碩
這個
呃 錦碩做了22口嘛
那星星有做了快
100張
就就這樣子 這個我們有配對
配對之外是偏多
喔 偏多
那星星是用星星賺買的 沒有錯
喔 用星星賺買的
喔 所以我是
反正我是做組合式交易啦
喔 有時候在高檔做組合式交易
喔 然後
這個信倉店是做那個
處置的短空 短空而已啦
那大力光板就不錯啦
大力光我們說那個三多顆啊 各位
三多哥尊重一點好不好 三多哥
再跟各位講一下 三多哥非常的厲害
這裡齁
哇 土聖傭明去買
唉唷 不是去買 賣掉 哇哩
土聖傭明也蠻厲害的咧
欸說真的蠻厲害的
那天去抄底
可以看一下 土聖傭明
欸這個厲害咧
抄底之後賣掉
我這天我也是去抄底啊
你可以
你可以再P1講
我待會再P1講說我們這個
明天的最新的雙道
喔
明天最新的雙刀
喔 那是雙刀很好玩啦
喔 雙刀很有趣
喔 很有意思啊
就雙刀就是一多一空
喔 所以在這個高檔的盤勢呢
其實做雙刀呢 其實相對來的穩健
喔 比較不用擔心啦
比較不用擔心說 買在高天
喔 那你也不用擔心說
欸 放空被尬什麼
你有多方部位可以保護
喔 那雙刀其實有很多做法嘛
一切有交給雙刀
例如說買台子期空00940
買台子期空00940
各位看一下
我們以前
這個很久以前
就寫篇文章講
買台子期空00940
那時候是2024年
2024年4月
就說買台子期空00940
那各位看一下
00940才剛
才剛怎麼樣
這個我們看一下
是這樣的
00940才剛
才剛這個
欸欸
才剛破10塊但是你看台子期你看台子期這2024年的4月到現在哇2024年的4月到現在你看看
你看你就知道說你買00940空台子期
你買台子期空00940有多賺了
學賺
買台子期空00940
台子期都快翻倍了
其實加雛電期早就翻倍了
對
台子期都翻倍了
我們那時候說買台子旗空靈90嘛
對不對
那這一招
到目前為止
都很好用
到目前為止都很好用
因為高股旗本來就是
比較不成才啦
那我們就說
欸你要領期你就
買
買旗幌你每個月
你每個月
不要說每個月你每天去領都可以
保證金夠每天去領都可以
每天去領都可以
然後呢這個
到目前為止還是正確的嘛
然後呢這個雙刀呢是我們會找同質性的股票
例如說8046啊 藍電啊
藍電喔各位你看我們之前是藍電配信心
那藍電配信心呢他的那個比值啊
他的比值
目前呢目前是
藍電好像稍微強一點
但是我覺得在下半週
下半週
現在已經是這個週三了
那在下半週
下半週有可能怎麼樣
有可能
那個星星會比藍電來得強
下半週
有可能
那種強是
是說像今天星星就比藍電強
今天星星就比藍電強
今天星星漲啊
藍電跌啊
今天星星是漲3%藍電跌
那為什麼
因為藍電有變成隔日補跌股
前天同類型的砂尾盤
隔天呢
它假如沒有跌 容易變隔日補跌
那這隔日補跌的概念 其實
我們做短線的 常常利用這個方法來做啦
那同樣的原理呢 各位你就可以去觀察
藍電跟錦碩 還有錦碩跟信心的關係
那這些關係呢
你都可以利用這些關係的那個強弱
還有處置的事件
來做雙刀
做雙刀就一刀一刀一刀啦
好啊一多一空呢其實
呃只要符合你預期的話
你就可以賺到這個
架叉收斂的錢
喔架叉收斂的錢
喔環球金跟中美金可以做雙刀當然可以啊環球金、中美金、台勝科喔都可以做雙刀但是呢 我們要有事件再跟各位講一次 要有事件
那什麼事件呢
這個
什麼事件啊
就是你要有儲置的事件
啊這種儲置的事件
儲置事件 那你要怎麼做呢
你要看儲置神器啊
好不好 各位你要看儲置神器
你要看他們的相關係數
看他們的偏差率
那個呢 在處置的比較
進階課程呢 我們有講
上次呢 我們在進階課有講
高麗蒼蠅配
沒了
高麗蒼蠅配沒有了
所以高麗蒼蠅這個
這個
呃 沒有錯 唉唷
土城有泥有超底望紅
哇塞
他是不是有偷看我啊
我買什麼 跟著我買什麼
我看一下
欸 厲害 我昨天買他也買
厲害喔 吐聲吽咽厲害喔
下通道的愛護者 呵呵 下通道愛護者
這個我今天要 我今天利用那個
嗯 處置神器呢 我還買了一些股票
今天有買一些
今天我有買這個
3167嘛 3167有買
3167啊
各位你看3167
這個儲置神器裡面有寫
喔有寫喔
這邊呢是開始分批進場的位置
喔我啦我分批進場的位置
2426我有買
今天有買在這個
51的時候
我買在51
最低50.5啊我買在51.1
唉唷收盤變54
收盤變54
好
那這都是那個
那個浪子回頭
給各位看喔 浪子回頭
我用desk in給各位看一下
desk in給各位看
desk in
來來來
等一下
我登錄一下desk in
好
这个
来 我登录DeskInk给各位看啦來 這就是我的手機啦手機
處置神器 今天就有
大量
我今天有買65%
有買到615
反正他往下殺就準備買
然後這邊呢有雙刀戰法
那今天呢這個通知啊
這通知幾個我都買
大量點員有買 欸台政哥沒買到
喔 台政哥沒買到
喔 這幾個
喔 大量點員
喔 就這樣
喔 這個 這是 浪子回頭
喔 那浪子回頭呢 後面呢 就有機會怎麼樣
東山再起
喔 我之前有買到波羅威啊
波羅威買在這地方
喔 對呀 買在這裡
喔
買在這邊呢 還在生氣
氣啊 氣我自己
喔 氣我自己太膽小
波羅威呢 在這個點位
喔 在這點位 來來來
波羅威這點位啊 這裡這點位
這點位我用康和券商來
我直接跟各位講我的分點
分點在康和
跟你講都沒關係
反正康和那麼大 又不是只有我一個
這波羅威我直接在康和買
在康和買這裡
這點位是我買的
氣啊
後悔 我嘴
到目前為止還在
郁悶
所以我為什麼那麼膽小呢
齁 這裡
齁 這個點
這個點
等一下 我看哪一點
這裡 這裡
這裡我佔20張而已
我買到20張
那邊22張嘛 我在這裡買到20張
盤後買 盤後掛了50張
掛50張 中2張
齁 盤後我掛了50張 中2張
欸 我來看一下
我來看一下那天盤後資訊怎麼樣
各位呢你可以看一下那個盤後資訊
這個盤後定價
盤後定價
我那天講台積電我盤後去買80張
一堆人在酸
你買80張我買800張
喔 喝啦喝啦你買80張
這算你厲害啦算你厲害
4月16號
我們來看一下4月16號這裡
4月9號這個都可以查喔
各位這個都可以查
這...這...
這不能亂來的啦
好不好 不能亂來
好 這都可以查
然後呢 呃...全部
齁 來 我們剛剛講那個
3163嘛 來這邊
3163這裡
欸 沒有 原來上櫃的
上櫃盤頭
那個上櫃上市都可以查
好 我來看一下 上櫃可以查
4月16號的上櫃
喔 4月16號上位
下載CSV
來 這裡啊 4月16號上位
欸
4月16號 欸
欸 我看錯了
對 16號 沒錯 16號的喔
來 16號上位給各位看一下
這16號上櫃的那個
那個盤喔
然後我找那個
找3163給各位看
反正我就掛了
我掛了50張啦
掛50張 中2張
唉唷
這裡
有沒有 這裡是怎樣 掛了
這中3張 唉唷
全市長中3張欸 哎呀 我運氣真好
雲綺貞好
前市長中三張
這個等一下再給各位看
這是微埋比數喔這邊
這太多了
太多了
我把這個弄給各位看
3163J
前市長
微埋比數74筆
尾賣張數146
喔 我尾賣張數3筆
我掛50筆中2張
我運氣不錯欸
喔 這邊是74筆中3張嗎
欸 差不多啊 因為我分散掛
喔 我賣 我掛50筆中2張
我掛50筆中2張
一對你覺得我在唬爛
算了 你覺得我在唬爛就在唬爛
反正我就中2張
喔 那我是盤後中20張
不是 收盤20張
然後盤後中2張
那我還在後悔 後悔怎麼樣
明明有200張可以讓我買 我為什麼只買20張
我應該應該狠狠的把這200張給敲掉不過沒有可能200張敲掉可能要準備太多錢了這個光融資可能也要準備8000萬
我的這個金額有點大
反正這個
這個喔
這個就是用康仁敲的
那這20張呢
給各位看 20張其實這兩天啊
各位你看一下
135的20張
其實隔天就蠻誇張的
隔天大概就90塊
隔天最高其實有到100塊
所以你買20張 隔天賺200萬
很誇張
他那個
他那個高加股漲起來真的蠻恐怖的
隔天賺200塊
隔天再漲
再漲70塊
所以你看這個位置多麼漂亮
這位置就在
就是怎麼樣 這位置就是我們的通知的這邊
各位
波羅威
給各位看
就這個位置啊 來來來
浪子回頭剝落為五天前嘛
各位21號五天前
喔 21號的五天前浪子回頭
位階小1等於5
標股近月線
就是這個訊息嘛
就這個訊息 浪子回頭
齁 然後呢
每兩天 就怎麼樣
東山再起
齁 每兩天都東山再起了 哇
這一下子
200萬其實不止啦 因為
這個
這一筆有一半是賣在隔天
再一些是賣在在隔天
所以呢這個波羅威整體的獲利是
超過200萬
只是現在還在後悔啦 還在覺得說
應該膽子大一點
有後悔自己
應該在這個位置應該要勇敢敲啊
這都已經短線跌那麼多應該再勇敢一點
下次呢 可能會再勇敢一點
在這位置呢 再敲多一點
因為短時間一下子跌65塊
這是千載難逢啊
好不好 千載難逢
就像今天的那個大量
大量為什麼買在這個位置
看起來
這裡啊 大量
各位看今天
這裡
大量
大量跌 等一下
一個是大量嘛
還有另外一個是
我今天有買這個經濟
啊經濟啊
經濟我買在這個點
這點我買一些就在這個位置啊162.5這點我買這點我買因為短時間跌這麼大
這是
這通常是一個好的買點
通常是好的買點
尤其他是強勢股
我們上禮拜就說經濟
經濟我們就期待他處置嘛
趕快處置
趕快回來
讓子趕快回頭
喔
經濟回頭
不是報恩就是報仇嘛
對不對
那經濟回頭是來報恩的好不好 報恩的好不好
各位呢 這個可能
之前賣飛了
現在經濟回頭是報恩的 我期待經濟可以回來
結果今天只有回來這麼一點點 又拉上去
我想說回來一點點 先接一點點 又拉上去
真的是
真的是拉得很快啊 所以這個
這處置呢真的很好玩啊
真的好玩
所以歡迎各位這個
用處置神器啊
好
怎樣
來來
一開場講太多
請各位加這QR Code
這QR Code
4個8
我們有實戰驗證
不定期分享雙刀戰法資訊
實戰成果
4個8喔
4個8
喔 不定期分享處置預測資訊
喔 對處置有興趣的同學提供互相討論的空間
喔 這個我們的討論群啊
喔 歡迎各位加一下 四個吧
啊 裡面股票都可以討論啊
喔 你要討論處置也可以討論
也可以 好不好
嗯 處置蠻有趣的 現在處置股票太多了
一牛車啊
喔
好
這個喔
這現在處置的股票一流的車
來來來
來 給各位看喔
現在的處置股票一流的車
那各位
這軟體呢 你要怎麼用齁
各位記得喔
這個我們會看那個
你要早買一點的喔
就位階低到高
位階低到高
然後呢 負的不要買
負的代表弱勢股啦
什麼綠核不要買 位數不要買
安慰不要買
這都弱勢付的不要買
月限協率付的不要買
那正的呢超過1呢 蠻值得買的現在大量來到月限協率2.8未位階來到4所以來到一個蠻甜蜜的點通常月線弦率1以上
位階4以下
就來到一個分批乘接的好位置
好不好
分批乘接的好位置
所以呢 這邊看起來
還有什麼豪眠啊
假如以色明天再疊的話也不錯
喔 瑞瑄今天我有買
好不好 我有買瑞瑄
瑞瑄今天買在這地方
瑞瑄今天點也是很漂亮啊
各位看一下瑞瑄
瑞瑄我今天買在好像是買在這個位置
這邊他也是瞬間疊啊
所以疊這麼一根
然後後面整個上去
中41點
欸?41點7吧
中一些
中這裡
那瑞瑄各位看一下
他也是回檔的好位置
啊瑞軒,瑞軒有個大戶喔
瑞軒有個大戶喔
今天他這個位置其實蠻漂亮的
齁在這位置蠻漂亮的
齁那瑞軒有個大戶啊
叫做這個給怪人
蠻厲害的松山哥
齁松山哥買的股票常常進處置齁
齁蠻狠的
齁各位看到
蠻狠的
齁目前賺9000萬
齁之前還有跌啊
之前還跌不怕成本
這有幾檔股票蠻強的 齁 齊邦
齊邦也是壯安哥有買
目前賺3億 齁 三億
喔 有沒有
真的太猛了 齁 太猛了
齁 最近這種強色的股票真的很猛耶
好 那各位呢 呃 你
明天呢 明天有這幾檔 這一檔假如有回檔的話
其實位置都不錯啊 假如訓星KY明天再跌啊
巨岸在跌 台盛科在跌
因為他們現在的位階都來到56
56呢 就比較甜蜜的位置了
比較甜蜜的位置
這邊呢 各位呢 可以
可以參考看看
那這邊 累幅呢 就是指說
他的那個 處置的時候
累積跌了多少
像大量處置已經累積跌了11%
也已經算是
蠻像樣的跌幅啦
喔 蠻像的蠟
那這幾個啊 各位可以看一下
假如來到那種
20% 30% 40% 喔
那個
那個勝率又更高
好 這是一個很有趣的交易啊
好啦 那歡迎各位
各位加這個群
喔 那我們的 呃 交易策略呢
呃 不定只會在PP上面分享
喔 各位呢 可以訂閱PP啊
訂閱PP呢 是
是瞭解最快的
喔PP呢 有
九折優惠券
喔 九折優惠券 在PP裡面
喔PP裡面
好
這邊
九折優惠券喔
好 那這幾個QR控各位也可以加
好 那四季投資法 呃 各位有興趣的也可以購買啦
那各位記得我們沒有人
呃 我跟小秘書都不會失去你啦
呃 沒空失去你 好不好
沒空 那我很忙
小秘書要去
呃 做很多客戶服務
所以沒有空
沒有空失去你
好 直播注意事項 這裡自己看
好 那我們看一下 哇 除了上了三次
每次都有不同說 公益善情並先利其計
感謝小哥與理財法開發強大軟體
讓儲值股票更有趣
得到軟體喔
這個購買4G課程喔
這個很多影片都值得從不看
學道太有引導小哥我是儲值課程
免費版常常到
我們儲值課上了4次
上4次了有很多人都上4次
好啦那這是學員的戰績喔
這個我們就不看了
那我們今天呢
今天給各位看那個
欸
尾全店1是可以逃離的
尾全店1可以逃離
那我們今天呢就可以讓
當選問一下問題啦齁
那我們可以看一下
最近的一些股票它的籌碼狀況
齁 我們可以看一下籌碼狀況
齁
那來看一下齁 那個量最大
量最大的大家最關心
好不好
量最大最關心齁 來來來
來
各位看一下齁
這個
今天成交量最大叫聯電
聯電 聯電重買也不錯
對不對
重買也不錯 主力是在買的
第二個是友達
友達最近回檔
欸 這個回檔看起來也還可以
還不錯啦
因為他是一個月線上升主力並不算大賣
假設
這條線跌的比主力來的快
來的深
那就是主力大賣
哎呀 這好像沒有比K線來得深那就不算主力大賣這這個友達群創量大了群創有點在做頭的味道
群創看起來秋天快到了
群創看起來是做頭的秋天
群創比較弱
台坡又再創高了
這是創高後的
已經創高了
台坡最近
京均在沒有處置來之後
最近變得很強
沒有儲置來之後變得很強
什麼叫儲置來? 儲置來就是天天注意啊
各位看一下
他這一出關之後沒有天天注意喔
最近才又開始
這個被儲置 但這個儲置是因為第一款
他是因為漲多了
但以前的儲置來是怎麼樣
儲置來是連黑K都注意
有沒有看到
以前連黑K都注意喔
那現在沒有喔 現在黑K沒有注意喔
這個黑K並沒有注意
所以以前有儲置來 以前有第六款
第六款如影隨行跟著它
現在都沒有了
下面有第六款
現在都是第一款
有一個第六款
這邊有第六款又出現了
又處自來了
金居到這位置又處自來了
本來之前在這裡已經治好了
但最近漲太多了
漲太多又開始處自來了
所以京居的走勢呢 可能又開始在一個區間震盪
京居可能又要在一個區間震盪
因為他又得處置癌了
得處置癌了
好
神器還會有另一個價格嗎
神器因為我們變為原價了
神器變貴了
各位需要的話我再請小命書開了
請小命書開了
好啦
這個今天神器講的
大家想買啊
小明書看要不要開
好不好
GIN
你決定嗎
你想開
之前的價格你就
你就決定看看
喔
那那先就要問理財寶啦
我主要這個沒有在碰行這塊
主要在
在分享我喜歡用的軟體
喔
金居喔
金居未來也會處置來喔
所以
金居呢他有可能到一個
就是從這個盤整區間
拉到下一個盤整區間
因為它現在開始有第六款
其實第一款沒什麼但是染上第六款啊染上第六款就麻煩再跟各位講染上第六款的股票是麻煩的
為什麼 因為各位你看啊
這邊第六款
第六款就是
他連跌也
連跌喔
連跌也第六款
就很麻煩了
所以他在這邊他完全上不去啊
那好不容易這裡終於沒有第六款了
想不到他拉了幾天之後 又開始有第六款
第一款不是矮
第一款漲多才會出現
第六款是矮
長期第六款我們都說他是處置矮
就是怎麼樣
長期第六款
我覺得別開了
對!很好
所有買軟體的人都建議小哥
小哥不要再賣了好不好
不要再賣了
自己賺就好
這是一堆人的心聲
賣個背啊
齁 大家自己
有買的自己玩就好
齁 不要再...不要再讓太多人進來
齁 不要讓太多人進來
蠻好玩的
好 那金居呢 今天唯一交割是這樣子
呃 他是放空
我跟你講 他不是做多喔
放空唯一交割
齁 在這裡 齁 在這邊啊
那個分點齁
分點呢 是群意稀松
齁 稀松歌啦
稀松平常的稀松歌
今天這個京居微小哥是4月17號
4月17號有個分點的叫西松哥
各位看一下
群義西松
來來來
西松 鳳山壇子
短前壇子鳳山彰化
我發現啊
欸我的稀鬆欸
稀鬆出來嗎 欸出來了
這裡
這裡啊
空空空空空空
補不回來
包不回來
補不回來 補不交割了
喔 有沒有
這個就是補不交割的狀況
喔 啊他的這個
張數也
所以加起來也算..算個..
算..算50張也沒多少錢啊
是怎樣怎麼..怎麼微交的金額那麼大看不到餒喔喔 跟著跟著這是買呵呵 我們要看賣
喔 要看賣喔
看賣看賣看賣
我們剛剛只看到買而已
來來來 我們要看賣
看他賣幾張啊
買只是回補的張數啦
喔 重點是在賣的張數喔
吸收
唉唷 吸收在哪裡啊
唉唷 看著 這裡
喔!喔!這麼強烈
喔!50張4張4張4張
喔!這人抓狂喔!
這個人應該是抓狂的
有沒有看到
50張4張4張4張
這是什麼大戶啊
130、160、200
200再加一加
喔!差不多300張啊
差不多!差不多!
喔!300張啊!
上億的微焦割嘛!差不多啊!
喔!
這個
這個...
京區違焦哥
哇!這邊
爆發違焦哥1.1億元
有沒有
喔!爆發違焦哥
這是群義西中啊
就他
那各位你看他,你看他的點位
這更很抓狂啊
這更很...
這個是
教書拔大
抓公
抓公開
喔這個
很恐怖啦
各位吳倦空呢
到這個位置最恐怖
吳倦空在這裡是最恐怖的
他其實當天還沒有
還沒有到排行榜
我看一下
到排行榜沒有
阿不會捏
連排行榜還沒進去捏
他還沒有進排行榜
然後空在這一天的
唉
我實在不曉得為什麼要空在這一天
說真的我不知道為什麼要空這一天啊
這一天沒什麼空的理由
跟郭哥講 這裡沒什麼空的理由
第一個 他沒有隔日沖啊
這黑黑隔天沒有隔日沖啊
這一天的隔天不會賭他隔日沖嘛
我們來看一下
你怎麼會賭
他的隔天是隔日沖啊
不會嘛 我們來看一下
你看4月16號
所以做股票錢要看籌碼嗎
買超
我們看4月16號
誰
10月之後
不會啊
這...不...不會
不會那個啊
你不會讀...
欸他...他庫長股喔
欸三位啦
欸那我來...這時候是庫長股啦
那金君拉雄啊
創新高時庫長股是怎樣啊
創新高時事庫長股
看不懂
好啦
法雲巴黎嘛
你也不會去賭法雲巴黎要隔日沖啊
你在這天都看到他連買兩天了
他怎麼可能賣在這一天
對不對
富邦也不會去賭他隔日沖啊
光法雲巴黎的籌碼我就不想空了啊
光法雲巴黎的籌碼我就不想空了
你知道嗎
這我一看從來就不想空了
更不會空在這一天
而且顏上尾
顏上尾不要空啊
嗯...
我不曉得他空的理由是什麼呢
我不知道空的理由是什麼
找不到
然後你...
你空的理由又這樣子
沿途空
哇這真的是很痛
這真的超痛
哇這遺憶很恐怖欸
欸遺憶
券商是可以
這遺憶隔天一定券差啊
捲叉啊 他這個沒有回來捲叉
喔 這捲叉還算賠得少欸
齁 這捲叉還算賠得少
因為隔天開的還不算高
367隔天還開373而已
有的捲叉滿狠的 一開7%
我自己打掉來了
啊 就這樣子啊 所以我覺得這個
可憐啊
好啦 來看一下今天可憲 可憲今天有夠狠
喔 哇塞 這個阻力誰幹的
喔 今天有個阻力憤力一拉
憤力一拉
我今天盤中有看到啊
我是玩奇貨 我應該玩現貨啊 怎麼沒有玩到現貨
有點可惜啊 結果呢 有人被
被騙了 富方人愛被騙了
喔 富方人愛是怎樣啊
欸
他有買了欸
伊小娜一起他是講欸他們家滑鼠卡住了
欸看起來有像喔
富方人愛他們家的貓
喔這看起來是富方人愛他們家的貓幹的喔
欸有像有像各位看一下喔
因為這很奇怪啊這裡啊
11.0015秒到11.025秒
300多張嘛
阿都同...這個...
從他拉起來到成交是同一個人
哇
他們家的鳥
齁這看起來是他們家貓幹的齁
因為...為什麼是他們家貓
因為正常人不會這樣幹啊
正常人怎麼會這樣幹呢
對不對 你怎麼會這樣買可塵 一路買
還...還漲停
齁 怎麼可能
不可能啦 你就錢太多 對不對
富庵人愛錢太多啊 富庵人愛是怎麼了
各位看一下 因為我今天看他盤中突然急拉
我想說 欸 富庵人愛在幹嘛
還是他戶頭被代操
他戶頭被代操 然後被拿來出貨了
各位戶頭記得不要給人家用啦
戴操是很危險的
富庵人愛他 他 他 他 他到底在幹嘛
富庵人愛在幹嘛
有沒有
你從啊
他買一買之後 鎖長庭
還真的買長庭
喔
這個點應該空他的 應該空爆他還對
又是後悔的一天
後悔沒空到
哇賽 元大爽欸
元大爽死了
喔元大爽死了
欸
該不會庫長股倒給他
這看起來是
滑鼠卡住了
這就像滑鼠卡住啊
怎麼有人在賣啊
結果遇到了蠶玉
蠶玉元大的刀
喔 蜂羽元寧厲害喔
喔 這蜂羽元寧讚
這個當中客人有看到這個點
哇 這點輕鬆30萬入袋
哎呀 我在做什麼期貨欸
因為我沒有講說那個漲停會成交
我
小時候知道掌停會成交
空爆他
後悔啊
後悔沒去空他
沒去空他這個位置太可惜了這種所以那個我們的當中神器啊先講可乘還掌
嗚 可乘還掌
然後
一瞬間成交之後
可乘還跌
嗯 又被還跌
喔 他是
一瞬間成交喔
這也是還掌嘛
喔 有沒有看到 這邊還掌
哇 這一瞬間欸
這都15秒
15秒一瞬間
一瞬間又跌下來
有沒有
你看這邊是一瞬間喔
從227到220這邊是一瞬間
都是15秒
一瞬間跌回來
16秒是217
我在玩期貨啦
我期貨有做到當充有賺
所以我的戶頭裡面
今天有期貨的
期貨本來我就有多單啊
可曾期貨本來今天就多單
所以我那個期貨有賺到啊
我賺的都一點點啊 沒有賺多少
這個是原本庫存的低價嘛
所以這個看起來賺很多
事實上那個當衝是賺不多啦
當衝賺不多
啊我今天南電我也做當衝
我今天南電當衝賺蠻多的
可是水衣看起來很醜
當衝賺很多 水衣看起來很醜
當衝賺不多 水衣看起來很漂亮
這個是那個以實踐跟未實踐之間的
這個 欸 欸 變化
那可成這個其實做現股就賺翻了
做現股就賺翻 好可惜啊
這點會沒弄到 因為
他沒多久之後呢 他又瞬間怎麼樣
他跌下來啊 跌下來之後就瞬間
緩跌
所以可成呢 是緩漲之後的緩跌
這蠻好玩的
7 6 我看一下
這邊
欸 那緩跌在哪邊啊
你看他後面又一瞬間又變緩跌
好像這一段嘛
反正就一段就緩跌了
哇
可惜啊
一秒緩漲一秒緩跌
喔
欸真的欸
喔這樣子嗎
06啊
我已經看到06啊
到底哪一秒緩跌了
我記得就瞬間緩跌
喔可能一瞬間啊 對不對
一瞬間又緩點
好南電怎麼虧那麼多 因為南電我們見得早啊藍店我們在做那個藍店星星配嘛
那藍店星星配其實到80塊我們就開始見
就是80塊見
然後呢 應該是我100塊見
我在他們兩個差100塊的時候見
那其中我到80 那昨天來到
昨天來到蠻多的 昨天來到100多吧
那今天又回檔了
今天藍店跟星星喔
各位你看喔 今天的藍店是
欸 其實我們這個配喔
我們的配呢 在這邊有雙刀戰法
給各位看一下
這裡啊
來 我找一下我的雙刀給各位看
這裡
雙刀 這裡
這邊
藍店啊
藍店這個
現在是欣欣處自己
這個筆子呢
是欣欣
這個除以藍店
這筆子是欣欣處於藍店
然後呢在昨天
昨天在這個位置
那我們是在
進來
欸應該
等一下
我的偏差率齁
我的偏差率大概在
這星星藍店
我們是在
好像是17號這邊開始弄
17開始弄
17的時候其實筆值
還一度還不錯
那後面昨天的筆值最醜
那今天又上來了 到0.9
所以我是
我是賭這個筆子變大
這筆子是星星除以藍店
那我賭他變大
那這變大有可能在
有可能在下半週會出現
那假如有一天星星超過藍店
這筆子就超過1
這筆子是星星除以藍店
那他們兩個相似度98%
所以我們會做
會做他們的一個
雙刀戰法
好 那明天
呃
星星除以南電
可能會換另外一個
換另外一組啦
可能就不會用星星南電了
會用另外一組
呃...沒買處置神器用當中神器也可以找
你可以找
這個...為何匯利分點一直鎖
錢多吧
錢多一直鎖啊
2022...2022...2022他就是這樣子啊
都沒什麼賞啊
沒什麼那個...就這樣
就...盤
呃...
玉金光怎麼看喔
相比玉金光 但大力光比較好啊
再跟各位講
再跟各位講 大力光呢
大力光
他是有CPO的
現在有CPO的本益筆齁
那個本益筆不知道怎麼看
有CPO的本益筆 看聯亞
聯亞本益筆到多少
聯亞本益筆到這裡幾千啦
喔 204
喔
波羅威
好 各位
這個
大力光的
他也是有CPU
好不好
喔
他的本益比是最少的
前幾天本益比還來到13
喔 有沒有
最近不是跌停嗎
喔
林恩平的法術會隔天跌停嗎
本益比來到13
現在本益比還要14
大力光是所有CPU裡面
CPU裡面 好不好
他的本益比是最低的
然後呢
他即便沒有CPU
因為CPU還沒有量產嘛
對不對 還在送樣而已
他即便沒有CPU
他一年賺了快200塊
各位有沒有看到
近世紀
一季賺50嘛
啊世紀有可能賺200嗎
近世紀賺159
大力光是這樣
你去看蓮亞
蓮亞到底賺多少
四塊
蓮亞賺四塊
這個是
這是因為現在多頭啊
我跟各位講 這是因為多頭啦
多頭就慶喘牛好不好
慶喘牛
等到有一天來到空頭了
那個殺下來的力道之狠
空頭的時候
你就知道大力光跟蓮亞
跟聯亞
誰會有成
那肯定是大力光所以現在CPU裡面你去追逐這些股票當然是很爽啦但是你要記得要跑得快一點
好不好
要跑得快一點
先追CPU
哇你看上全
你自己看這本益比
聯亞碳細CQ
上全賺0.16
有沒有看到
今天CPU都是 你哪有CPU
還有一堆沒有CPU的
還有一堆沒有CPU說自己有CPU
然後呢 股價噴的亂七八糟的
那這些未來
再跟各位講 未來總有一天
一定會反噬
一定會反噬的啊 只是不曉得那一天什麼時候到而已
你現在也不用去哄他
我只是跟你講說
你真的要做多好不好 各位 做多
做多安全一點
好不好
這個一劑賺50,四劑賺200
假如一劑賺50,四劑賺200嘛
那我不曉得未來三劑怎麼樣了
啊至少
啊至少這是
本業比比較
比較低的嘛
各位那買股票現在都瘋了
現在這些人都瘋了對不對
啊這這
這誰都瘋了
各位
這到底是誰瘋了
喔
到底是誰瘋了
這裡嘛
各位看一下
這裡就是他
他就瘋了啊 有沒有
9811就瘋了 好不好
9811國外都很瘋了
大家都瘋了 反正這
現在大家有錢 大家一直去搶那些
那個賺沒多少錢的
這個反正開心啦 大家開心就好
因為現在大家
只要有人進來
只要這個市場一直有人進來
這泡泡就不會破
好不好
這泡就不會破
那等到有一天
有一天沒有人進來了
等到有一天你看到國泰燈不買了
買完了
散乎沒錢啊
那時候
騰炮就差不多了
因為最近國泰燈買得很誇張啦
國泰燈最近買得很誇張
買得很誇張
所以這泡泡還在膨脹中
好不好
981A主力天大賣
這沒什麼啦
這個是肇事者啊
喔...Marketmaker在大賣
沒什麼
喔...Marketmaker本來就會賣
喔...
那重點是賞物在大賣他...他...他主力...主力是...造勢者啦造勢者在大賣嘛 有沒有
造勢者在大賣
然後呢 導致的啦
回歸到前面就跟各位講
目前呢 在一個泡泡膨脹的階段
泡泡膨脹的階段 各位你就享受這泡泡吧
享受嘛 你看我有享受啊
我這樣子嫌棄波羅威 我也買波羅威
呵呵
我會買不老花啊
喔因為這點位漂亮嘛
所以我 我也是買啊
他百億比這麼大我還是買啊
沒辦法啊因為那個店就不錯啊
各位你自己看 沒辦法
好不好
主力沒大賣的拉回是讓你做多的嗎對不對
喔 光從技術面從馬面那你就是要買啊
對不對 沒有問題的好不好
基本面我當然是不想買啊
我是不想買啦 但是
啊但是因為處置神器出現了嘛
所以我就買一點嘛
假如這一天是大力光出
假如這個訊號是大力光
喔買他個200張好不好
就買200張啊
就是因為他叫波羅威嘛
那叫大力光我就買他200張
因為我就相信大力光啊
對不對啊波羅威
啊買少一點買個20張
欸買個20張也驚人欸
買個20張各位噴兩根也是大概300萬
然後我們傻怕玩20張就300萬
這個也蠻恐怖的啦
我是覺得
也蠻恐怖的
這個那個
最近的DOTTO
真的很恐怖
好
981A肇事者的貨哪裡來呢
你買它就有啊
你買它就有好不好
你買它就有
所以呢這個
你只要一直買
它就一直有
ETF是這樣子喔
ETF他是沒有那個
那個量是你一直買他就有
好了
那我們有一個股票期貨實戰班
在5月15號台中廠
5月17號高興廠
5月23號台北廠
副會直播是5月23號
教各位股票期貨
這個就是我今天股票期貨的戰績
那我們股票期貨呢
股票期貨連雙刀都會做
好不好
雙刀都會做
來這裡
只是期貨啦
其實我用期貨來做很多交易
期貨做很多交易好啦來來來來然後呢商一下喔今天買籌碼K線呢有443檔大部分點清單
歡迎各位
這購買
接下來這個交易筆記本
交易筆記本
各位呢這個
可以訂閱啦
有什麼問題呢
都在上面都可以問
好
那最後呢
最後喜歡今天直播
歡迎按讚訂閱喔
留一觀看心得
看新的
喔 然後
欸
等一下
喔 抽幾毛或軟體喔
欸 你現在有QA時間喔
那個後面有抽獎
是抽軟體喔
來 股票集合43班
台中行是幾要上課啦
喔 幾要上課
線上亂數產生氣
我們來看一下
好
來吧
29跟11
喔29跟11
中獎
好啦
非常感謝今天各位的觀看
齁
來來來
5月的古籍課程跟新系課程類似嗎?
呃...5月的還有一些新的東西啦
其實有新的東西就會...就會有
造勢者怎麼到貨給買...
你那個...你那掛單...你以為這掛單誰掛的?
這就是MakiMaker掛的啊
你以為賞物掛那麼多?
你自己看,這是MakiMaker啊
掛那麼密耶
很多散物牌的就沒在掛單了啦
這很多都是MakiMaker掛的啦
他掛那麼密就讓你買啊
喔
掛那麼密要讓你買的
主治神器
月角,呃不知道
好,各位有什麼問題呢?歡迎問一下
問一下我要準備來那個
神盾集團喔
神盾集團
該不會又要作帳了吧
〔此段辨識失敗，約 1:10:00 起〕